[Musique]
on aura le monde qui possède l'afrique
possédera le monde c'est le genre de
conversation compte entre le lait les
grands de ce monde g8 ce genre de
conversation c'est ce qu'ils disent mais
ces conversations sont absents les
principaux concernés c'est-à-dire les
les africains les africains qui d'abord
ne se connaissent pas qui ne savent pas
qu'ils sont qui n'ont pas idée du
potentiel qu'ils représentent et qui ne
réalise toujours pas que si en chat il
pouvait se mettre ensemble oublier leurs
quelques différences mais se concentrer
sur ce qui fait leur ressemblance est
bien l'afrique pourrait avoir sur ce
monde une influence extra ordinaire mais
ne le savent pas et la conversation
continue celui qui à l'afrique aura le
monde et nous sommes absents de cette
conversation
voilà le premier défi selon moi que
l'afrique reviennent enfin aux africains
à jour mais n'écoutez pas ce que je dis
en essayant de penser à un africain qui
a bien réalisé que son continent et
spoliés et qu'il est vide et de ce qui
lui est essentielle mais il ya plus que
cela
ça c'est le premier degré je voudrais
vous emmener au second degré où je crois
que je suis arrivé où j'essaie d'en
marquer maintenant plusieurs personnes
avec lesquelles je converse
régulièrement mais pour qu'on comprenne
cela je vous poser quelques questions et
puis vous allez vous répondre à vous
même et vous comprendrez ou est-ce qu'on
peut arriver à cela est ce que vous
pensez et j'ai tellement aimé les
conversations que j'ai entendu avant
droit
parce qu'ils ont juste préparé cette
conversation c'est extraordinaire ce que
vous avez fait avant est ce que vous
pensez vraiment que la destination des
sommes que nous sommes c'est le juste
produire pour consommer pourquoi cette
course effrénée tout le temps à courir à
vouloir aller plus vite plus loin plus
rapidement à chercher des raccourcis
sans penser aux déséquilibres que nous
créions sans s'occuper des vies que nous
détruisons sans penser à la
surexploitation de ce que nous avons
reçu gratuitement et au fait que nous
sommes en train de tuer tout ce que nous
avons et nous préparons des joue
vraiment difficile est ce qu'en réalité
mesdames messieurs nous ne sommes pas
des des pyromanes qui s'improvisent
quelquefois comme pompier malades
heureusement dans votre pardon et qui
évidemment pour réparer les mots que
nous avons fait pour rééquilibrer tout
ce que nous avons déséquilibré nous sur
excitons la science et nous disons le
problème du monde c'est l'énergie
non le problème c'est pas l'énergie
c'est que tu en as suffisamment mais tu
en veux tellement que tu doit fabriquer
plus est dans le process tu détruis tous
les maux qui prospèrent les maladies qui
prospère aujourd'hui ne sont elles pas
juste la conséquence de mode de vie
exacerbé de consommation trop importante
je pense que le vrai défi du monde
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut que j'eusse
membres de l'union humain il faut qu'on
redevienne humaine ne sommes pas des
machines
nous sommes la création la plus parfaite
mais cette création a besoin d'être ce
qu'elle est redevenue mais alors qu'est
ce que ça veut dire d'être
être humain c'est engager une
conversation avec quelqu'un qu'on ne
connaît pas être humain c'est prendre le
temps de s'asseoir d'observer la nature
êtres humains c'est respecter la
différence qui avec l'autre et de ne pas
voir un sujet de crispation dans la
différence mais au contraire un sujet
d'enrichissement êtres humains c'est
respecter et mais pardonnez être patient
vivre une vie selon un cycle normal
comprendre qu'un enfant s'amuse neuf
mois et que c'est un homme et une femme
qu'il faut un enfant et que donc
conséquemment c'est un homme et une
femme qui font une famille et que donc
conséquemment on ne doit pas chercher
accélérée des choses qui ne sont pas
acceptables qu'un pour nier sa main un
temps pour fonder une pomme et qu'un
qu'une patate ça prend le temps que ça
fait voilà c'est tout simplement ça être
humain mais pour être humain c'est pas
difficile il suffit juste se souvenir
que nous sommes d'abord un fils ou une
fille puis un frère ou une soeur puis
6-2 le vieux un époux oublier pouces et
éventuellement un père ou une mère c'est
tout il faut que nous revenons que nous
revenions pardon à ceux qui nous est
fondamentale j'aime beaucoup cette
sagesse en afrique du sud mais parce
qu'on ne connaît pas on n'aime pas on ne
peut aimer que ce que l'on connaît il
faut que nous connaissions l'afrique et
je vous assure j'ai commencé un parcours
ya quelques années le fait de connaître
mon afrique fait que je n'aime
vraiment la deuxième condition il faut
que nous aimions l'afrique
la troisième condition il faut que nous
comprenions que chacun de notre place
nous pouvons contribuer il faut que
chacun de sa place s'engage pour devenir
un acteur conscient du développement et
je voulais dit il suffit juste de se
souvenir qu'on ait un fils ou une fille
un frère ou une soeur un père ou une
mère est l'époux ou une épouse et c'est
tout ce qu'il faut il n'est pas besoin
d'elle chef de l'état je n'en veux même
pas il n'est pas besoin d'être direct 8
et c'est pas important
il n'est pas besoin d'être le chef du
grand communauté il suffit juste d'être
conscient que de sa place la petite
chose que tu dois bien faire et ce
qu'ils m'ont président tellement dit il
suffit qu'on le fasse pour qu'ensemble
nous arrivions la transformation que
nous souhaitons bon nous et gilles
attali je suis un fier africain je
n'aime jamais donné le pays d'où je
viens parce que ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance
je suis un fier africains et toute ma
vie je les passais à causer fonction du
feu mon père a beaucoup voyagé puis moi
même ma carrière aujourd'hui mais fait
le voyage est extrêmement et je retrouve
dans ce continent puis j'aime tellement
de choses extraordinaires que le temps
ne permettrait pas de partager avec vous
mais je sais qu'au delà des trois
conditions que je vous ai donné qu'ils
sont devenus le terreau sur lequel
travaille une initiative panafricaine
que j'ai fondée il ya un an qui
s'appelle afrique consciente et bien
j'ai compris qu'au delà de ces trois
conditions
le regard différent sur nous mêmes le
regard différent sur l'afrique l'absolue
nécessité de sa place s'engager de faire
juste son devoir
il ya deux choses également qu'il faut
que l'on comprenne
et que d'en face si lv3 priorité pour
l'afrique
elles sont les suivantes l'éducation
l'éducation est encore l'éducation
éducation le socle fondamental du
progrès de l'afrique
nous ne pouvons pas parler d'émergence
si nous n'avons pas des populations de
choses c'est que la jeunesse n'est pas
le futur de ce continent c'est faux la
jeunesse en est le présent il faut que
la jeunesse soit maintenant là tout de
suite tout de suite parce qu'elle va
diriger demain
j'entendais je ne parlais de 4e cat rie
saissac à fait conscient du fait
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle appelle à une
vraie responsabilisation de chacun des
trous en disant on ne peut plus
continuer à pointer le doigt sur
quelqu'un ou se gausser du passé pour
trouver des excuses il faut que chacun
maintenant face au chemin disciplinaire
de responsabilité en acceptant de se
bouger un peu plus qu in fine en
acceptant d'avancer un peu plus vite que
l'avancé avant en acceptant de se dire
la vérité des fois même si ça peut faire
un peu mal l'on comprend pas que au bout
tout si tu n'es pas je ne peux pas être
moins de ma place je me suis engagé à
fait consciente aujourd'hui propose que
le développement de l'afrique ne soit
pas sur les chemins et sur les routes
les sentiers qu'on a pavé devant nous
pour lesquelles nous savons très bien
que nous n'avons pas la solution
une continuant c'est juste c'est pas
marrant c'est juste incroyable que nous
réalisions que les chemins qu'on a mis
devant nous ne marche pas mais que nous
continuons à marcher dessus
l'afrique peut réussir son développement
réellement de manière sûre de manière
durable de manière constructive et
inclusive pour nous et pour tout le
monde
nous basons notre développement sur le
sol de ce qui fait notre vraie identité
et nos valeurs
les chaudes nous avons honte et que nous
ouvrions remettre au goût du jour
toutes ces choses que nous avons
apprises avec nos aînés et qui sont
partis qui partent en lui il faut
revenir à cela l'afrique peut le faire
et c'est ce que afrique conscient du
juste avec neuf mois d'existence
il va faire une communauté de 25000
personnes aujourd'hui rien ne pourra se
faire si au départ ne sommes pas
conscients j'hésite à l'ancienne appel
mais je dois vous dire la vérité il faut
que vous vous engagez chacun de votre
place hommes comme femmes vieux comme
jeunes enfin moi je n'ai je ne veux dire
ça comme ça sinon je me suis moi même
qui a dit que j'étais vieux donc il faut
que chacun d'entre nous nous engageons
véritablement afrique a besoin de nous
c'est comme si une mère amie des enfants
monde
ces enfants ont grandi et que ses
enfants ne s'occupaient pas d'elle
soyons fiers de ce que nous sommes
engagez vous et pour ceux qui le peuvent
vous pouvez nous rejoindre
[Musique]